je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui qui est
une vraie maladie une mythomanie il a
été condamné 17 fois pour des mensonges
il y a des vrais victimes qui sont pas
très contentes de le voir se mettre en
avant comme ça donc voilà je pense
quelqu'un qui a des difficultés je vais
pas tirer sur une ambulance en face
aujourd'hui il a souhaité ne pas venir
corrien il a dit voilà il s'exprimer
hier je voulais pas être en face de
Damien Rio alors aujourd'hui vous il
vous reproche de poster tout ce qu'on
vous envoie alors en l'occurrence il est
journaliste et moi un journaliste je
crois en la crédibilité de la presse et
donc si un journaliste m'envoie une
information je considère que je n'ai pas
à la vérifier j'ai quand même vérifier
le lieu où ça a été journaliste tous les
journalistes qui donnent des bonnes
informations ah bah visiblement en tout
cas il faut s'en méfier je suis d'accord
avec vous appeler avant je vous aurais
dit voilà
mais n'empêche qu'on ne rigole mais il
joue avec la déontologie puisqu'il n'a
pas le droit de de faire ça d'avoir
c'est un moyen déloyal donc je pense que
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave par
contre
je trouve que c'est voilà c'est un c'est
un happning voilà je trouve pas que ce
soit voilà je trouve pas ça j'ai pas
trop excité c'était très grave je trouve
qu'il y a des journalistes qui font
beaucoup plus grave que lui qui font des
c'est un sujet sérieux quand même je
pense qu'on devrait pas rigoler avec ça
alors vous ayez pas rigolé hein il a pas
rigolé c'était une démarche voilà pour
dénoncer en fait le fait pour postiez
que des des choses islamophobes c'est ce
qui nous a dit je vois pas ce qu'il y a
d'islamophobe poster des gens qui sont
en train de prier qu'est-ce qu'il y a
des islamophobe expliquez-moi alors
dispositif
j'entends ce que vous dites mais je
comprends pas bien vous voulez en venir
parce que d'un côté vous nous dites que
ce garçon quand il est Gwen est malade
mythomane et en même temps vous dites je
l'ai pris au sérieux immédiatement donc
là il y a un truc qui va pas soit vous
le prenez au sérieux parce que vous
dites c'est un journaliste soit vous
dites c'est un malade mental et donc je
je crois que c'était avant voilà je
savais pas moi j'ai vu qu'il était
journaliste j'ai regardé un peu dans
Google il y avait des articles qui
montrait qu'il avait travaillé pour des
médias tout à fait crédible et puis en
cherchant finalement le twitter a
enquêté et ils sont remonter beaucoup
d'articles de condamnation et des
victimes aussi qui ont pris la parole
sur Twitter pour dénoncer son compte
alors dernière Rio en fait ça c'est
c'est ce qu'a fait un petit peu Camille
la lumière sur ce que beaucoup de monde
vos reproches puisque il y a beaucoup de
gens qui vous reprochent d'inciter la
haine contre les musulmans sur les
réseaux sociaux tout le temps sans cesse
Lydia je crois qu'elle vous suit
énormément que ce qu'on réponde à ça
voilà oui mais tu tombes dessus mais à
chaque fois ça te prend la tête
plusieurs matins je me réveillerai où le
thé c'est pour ça que j'ai bien content
d'être en face de vous et justement on
va voir les tweets de Damien arrive donc
voilà et voilà donc c'est c'est des
tweets qui sont passés donc on en a
parlé hier voilà poster souvent des gens
qui sont en train de faire la prière
dans dans des lieux publics quand on
vous dit que vous postez des choses à
chaque fois qui qui incite à la haine
contre les musulmans vous répondez quoi
moi je je travaille sur le phénomène de
l'islamisation et donc toutes les
preuves de cette islamisation toutes les
la visibilisation de l'islam sous
différentes formes ça peut être les
jeunes femmes par exemple comme vous qui
veulent que y ait le voile islamique
dans les tribunaux ça peut être
l'offensive islamique à l'école avec des
jeunes filles qui veulent rentrer dans
les dans les lycées avec leur voile
islamiques ça peut être les horaires de
piscine ça peut être le halal dans les
cantines ou alors le fait qu'il n'est
plus de porc dans les cantines il y a
plein de si vous voulez de de symptômes
qui montrent une islamisation du pays
moi je m'intéresse assez symptômes et
donc lorsque j'envoie et bien je les
partage et quand vous les partager c'est
dans quel intérêt pour montrer justement
ce qui est en train de se passer
c'est-à-dire une islamisation
c'est une islamisation de la France il y
a des symptômes de cette islamisation et
donc je le montre tout à fait parce que
vous recevez des candidatures
justement j'allais dire en toute
honnêteté le monsieur donc le
journaliste qui vous a envoyé cette
photo vous vérifiez pas à chaque fois
qui est-ce qui vous envoie la photo tant
que vous avez à manger vous le partagez
ça que vous faites parce que ça
m'étonnerait que tous les journalistes
toutes les photos que vous avez publié
que ce soit à chaque fois des
journalistes qui vous les envoyer
et auxquels j'ai confiance ça peut être
des militants de reconquête par exemple
ça peut être voilà des gens ou alors je
vérifie qu'est-ce qu'ils ont tweeté ces
dernières semaines ces derniers mois si
je vois que c'est des gens qui sont pas
hostile et qui sont plutôt dans mes
idées il y a aucune raison qui me piège
je recoupe aussi les arcs
quels sont vos idées là-dessus parce que
moi j'ai vu voilà des tweets voilà vous
avez mis vous avez mis un tweet par
exemple en plus de dépenser de l'argent
public pour des projets humanitaires à
l'étranger nouvelle Aquitaine banalise
et promeux le voit l'islamique dans une
campagne publicitaire je vais vous
montrer les différents tweets que vous
avez fait comportement et regarde
pervers on dit stop témoin de
harcèlement sexiste trois conseils pour
agir rapprochez-vous de la personne
harcelée ou agressée adressez-vous à la
victime comme si vous la connaissiez
prévenez un agent TCL ça vous aviez
reposté voilà pourquoi le terme banalisé
comme si c'était quelque chose d'illégal
c'est pas illégal le voile je ne dis pas
que c'est illé je dis que c'est un
symptôme de l'islamisation de mon pays
selon vous de notre pays selon vous il y
a pas et c'est quoi l'islamisation et
vous vous êtes le docteur c'est ça parce
que les symptômes c'est par exemple le
fait que le nombre de musulmans dans mon
pays a été multiplié par 1000 en 70
dollars que le nombre de mosquées a été
multiplié par 1000 en 70 ans et alors
j'ai pas envie de devenir le Pakistan
c'est pas envie de devenir l'Arabie
Saoudite j'ai pas envie que mon pays
devienne le Libanais mais vous avez
conscience parce que vous définissez
comme un lanceur d'alerte je me permets
de vous rappeler que le lanceur d'alerte
il dénonce des crimes ou des délits
on sort le code pénal mais vous savez
moi je vais vous répondre sur
l'argumentation d'alerte vous alertez de
quoi est-ce que vous êtes pénal et les
lois de la République elles n'ont pas
été conçues une époque où il y avait des
musulmans dans notre pays
le droit il n'est pas adapté à la
présence de millions de musulmans et des
missions
va devoir se corriger pour pouvoir
répondre à la tentative de conquête de
l'islam de l'espace public
en regardant vos publications mais là la
vérité dangereuse mais là voilà votre
vérité votre vérité c'est que vous
détestez les musulmans il faut le dire
que vous savez vous êtes obsédé depuis
des années dans les musulmans je vous
les montrer dans les pays arabes
musulmans
facilement
que vous êtes un idéologue d'extrême
droite vous avez été de génération
idéologique c'est juste une réelle
non c'est votre réel fantasmer de la
haine des musulmans
aujourd'hui
c'est qu'en fait son groupe a été
dissout pour provocation à la haine et
il se prétendent leur défendre pour
avoir simplement fait une frontière
symbolique justement
qui a crié au nom de allahu akbar et qui
a qui tuer pardon qui a blessé très
gravement plusieurs personnes à la gare
du Nord vous savez ces gens-là c'est des
gens qui passent par la frontière et
donc symboliquement quel rapport avec
les musulmans qui sont en France
depuis 1970 le nombre de mosquées en
France a été multiplié par 24 et le
problème c'est la laïcité c'est ça qui
est beau je crois pas il y avait j'ai
dit depuis 70 ans pas depuis 1970 sur
mon avis
en 1950 il y avait que la Grande Mosquée
de Paris la grande mosquée de la réunion
ce que ça vous dérange de votre
quotidien mais ce qui me dérange c'est
que mon pays est en train de venir le
Pakistan et je n'ai pas du tout là
en quoi est en train de devenir regardez
regardez le public regardez le public
nous on a un prix d'avoir un public
vraiment qui représente je trouve la
France aujourd'hui ça splendeur et c'est
vrai que regardez qu'est-ce qui vous
dérange dans le public et personne n'a
vu quelqu'un qui est dans la rue quand
vous voyez des gens qui sont issus de
l’immigration
qui sont issus de l'immigration
qui font des réussites exceptionnelles
en France qui est emploi des des des des
des centaines de personnes qui sait très
bien moi voilà
comme avocat ou pas est-ce que je
pourrais le prendre comme fille
un avocat doit prendre tous les clients
un avocat normalement on doit pouvoir
défendre tout le monde là devant tout le
monde oui mais on choisit ses clients
quand même
préférait l'avocat du du libyen qui a
fournir des gens
[Applaudissements]
vous la prendriez comme avocat ou pas du
tout je pense que sur les problématiques
moi je suis attaqué par les islamistes
qui essaie de me faire taire donc je ne
prendrai pas une islamiste pour me
défendre
à mon avocat par contre pour diffamation
et c'est pour un jour public que je suis
islamiste
par exemple qui veut la mort des
homosexuels vous savez sur votre compte
Twitter j'ai regardé un petit peu les
lives depuis quelques mois j'ai vu vous
êtes en fin de parmi tant d'autres
typiquement et du coup quand vous likez
à la fin de l'émission sur mon compte
twitter il y a pas de souci
il y a des islamos
madame a liké certaines sourates par
exemple la sourate 40 verset 60 qui
finit par ceux qui se refusent à
m’adorer entreront bientôt en enfer vous
avez liké la sourate 2 verset 286 qui
finit par tuer notre maître accord de
nous donc la victoire sur les infidèles
vous avez liké la sourate 23 verset 6
qui explique qu'on a le droit de faire
l'amour à ses esclaves voilà et puis
vous avez liké aussi le prédicateur ou
taillamine qui réclame la peine de mort
pour les homosexuels donc Madame voilà
avec le
mararaden par exemple les gens vont
comprendre peut-être que vous avez pas
liké
et puis une communication
il m'a démasqué alors je vais lui
répondre ça va très très simple écoutez
moi bien déjà un on était là pour parler
de votre Twitter à vous pas d'humain et
le mien je sais que vous ne craquez
depuis quelques mois je l'ai vu vous
avez si vous avez regardé quelque chose
attendez je vais aller jusqu'au bout moi
vous me faites pas peur moi je tremble
de la personne non mais vous allez
m'écouter non mais vous allez moi je
vous ai laissé parler moi je tremble
devant personne je suis droit dans mes
bottes je suis très transparente et je
suis très bien ce que je fais je suis
très intègre alors écoutez-moi bien non
seulement j'ai liké les versets qui les
qui dit ils sortent du Coran mais en
plus je l'ai dit puisque c'est dans mon
livre c'est dans le Coran et j'assume
complètement maintenant si on prend des
versets qui sont pris de leur contexte
et qui sont pris ah là il y avait rien
de mal je parle attendez je parle pas
encore du tweet euh de l'autre là je
parle des versets du Coran précisément
vous ouvrez le Coran il y a tout écrit
dessus vous doutez bien que si je suis
musulmane et que si je porte un voile je
lis ce livre on est d'accord maintenant
a-t-on la science pour prendre des
versets comme ça et de liker comme ça et
vous êtes bien malin parce que pendant
la pub quand vous m'avez montré les les
versets là vous avez cité la fin de
versa vous avez pas citer ensemble mais
ça on y passera c'est pas grave ensuite
on va revenir au au savon donc je dis
aux gens parce qu'il a très mal prononcé
mais c'est cher au timing donc c'est un
symbole c'est bien ce monsieur
visiblement vu je connaissais comme je
connais votre nom alors vous êtes
quelqu'un d'un femme je connais aussi
votre nom donc c'est ça va c'est un
savant d'Arabie Saoudite si il me semble
il a quelqu'un mais pas du tout j'ai
jamais mis les pieds mais qu'est-ce que
vous me raconter alors là ils sont toute
la panoplie je vous ai un truc il y a eu
des rigolo avant vous il y a eu des
Messia il y a eu des hauts d'où il y a
eu des amours vous vous êtes le dernier
ouais vous vous êtes le dernier d'une
longue liste
je vais m'expliquer
la citation que j'ai aimé les gens sont
bien je voulais juste savoir si j'y
connais rien si ce monsieur que vous
avez reliké et respectivement
j'ai relaqué j'ai j'ai liké une citation
spirituelle qui n'avait absolument rien
à voir si vous voulez dire cette station
vous dites monsieur
au courant de ces positions du tout j'ai
même pas lui c'est des kill la personne
qui l'a dit la citation m'a plu je l'ai
aimé ah parce que toutes citations qu'on
a aimé donc on peut pas dire du Céline
Dion
homophobe je crois mais sinon si vous me
dit d'un côté ça je savais pas qu'il
avait des twittes homophobes ça vous
comprenez pas cet homme n'a pas Twitter
je crois il me semble en fait
rien à voir avec le sujet de
l'homosexualité une citation que j'ai
trouvé jeudi j'ai même pas regardé qu'il
a dit j'ai aimé d'accord et quand bien
même j'avais vu je ne suis pas au
courant de déposition de ce monsieur là
et moi je vais vous dire un truc parce
que là ça fait déjà la plusieurs fois
dès qu'on voit une musulmane avec un
voile en fait vous vous êtes pas content
vous tremblez parce que vous avez dit
une communication excellente je parle
mieux que vous vous avez rien à mon
prochain vous abonnez-vous vous avez
voulu me faire une Manelle vous avez
voulu regarder mes tweets est-ce qu'elle
a aimé un truc sur la Syrie nana il y a
rien sur moi monsieur il madame a aimé
des citations c'est tout ce que j'ai
fait et vous tout ce que vous relayez et
vous ce que vous vous êtes à l'ensemble
vous êtes à la sorte de bombes vraiment
heureusement que le ridicule ne tue pas
mais la haine que vous véhiculez elle
elle tue et vous vous êtes un homme
dangereux moi écoutez-moi bien moi je
suis moi je suis étudiante en droit moi
je fais des malades personne j'ai fait
du mal
par contre vraiment vous préparez vous
donner à pleurer et c'est vraiment
vraiment triste parce que vous avez vu
en enfer ou pas
franchement mais tout le monde vous
faites vous êtes burlesque tout le monde
ici vous serez ridicule vous êtes un
disque rayé mais bien sûr que non je ne
vais pas l'avoir en homosexuel mais et
on en a se poser cette question là
première mon humanité parce que j'envoie
sur la tête et bah interrogez-vous dans
votre corps arrêtez de parler sur
Twitter on dira photomaton le gars il
est diffusé photos toute la journée il
sait même pas ce qu'il dit vous êtes là
vous redoutez des trucs vous êtes
difficile
écoute j'aimerais bien j'ai juste un
petit truc je dis juste un petit truc là
les musulmans qui se taisent et qui ont
peur c'est fini moi je suis droit dans
mes badges j'ai vraiment vous ne me
faites pas peur ah oui c'est fini
regardez-moi bien c'est terminé
maintenant vous avez une femme j'en ai
dans la tête je suis une femme je porte
un voile je suis comme en français parce
que moi le plus français le drame avec
la tuerie avec les euh
il a oublié il a oublié je pense à toi
parce que vous Twitter à chaque fois
il y a des clandestins qui tue des
Français très régulièrement dans les
malheureusement je n'ai pas
l'exhaustivité régulièrement mais pas
Twitter pour relayer je ne suis pas une
agence de fait divers au phénomène
je ne suis pas mais
l'info c'est passé sur toute
l'actualité
logique vous êtes seul
par exemple monsieur c'est le paddle
voilà chacun
vous avez plus vous amuser hein non mais
c'est vrai et vous serez marié
[Rires]
et donc vous êtes contre les prières de
rue aussi des catholiques intégristes
par exemple oui il y en a régulièrement
d'ailleurs on est il y a plein de prix
dans la rue c'est bien connu madame moi
je suis content et prière de rue de dans
toutes les rues et pour toutes les
religions mais précisément vous êtes
donc contre les prières de rue des
musulmans contre la contre les prières
de rue des versions pourquoi pas le
bouddhisme
je vous demande juste si vous vous êtes
contre à titre personnel intime par
rapport à enfin en tant que citoyen ce
que vous êtes contre mais vous savez on
peut pas comparer déjà
la France a une culture chrétienne vous
dérange pas par exemple quelques siècles
ça compte vous savez donc on peut pas
mettre tout sur un même plan et
aujourd'hui on a peine on appelle 70 ans
il y a une islamisation très rapide
la société avec différents symptômes et
aujourd'hui il y a une offensive parce
que l'islam est une religion de conquête
et inoffensive pas du tout à l'école
madame voulait dans les tribunaux sur la
voie publique
pour combattre des islamistes encore en
fait merci de me
au dessus des lois de la religion
n'est-ce pas la dernière fois et je vous
avais déjà examiné que je suis très
important parce que on est attaqué par
le monde musulmanes
comme tous les jours
vous êtes de la famille d'André
j'ai une question pour vous monsieur
cette maladie c'est obsession
ça remonte
[Musique]
ils veulent nous conquérir je vous
signale que la religion musulmane c'est
une religion de paix oui
mais bien mais d'ailleurs le prophète
Mahomet n'est pas un guerrier c'est une
religion de paix non mais là vous êtes
en train de dire des des autres c'est
une religion de paix où chacun
est vierge et vous dites que vous êtes
que vous ressentez plusieurs fois parce
que moi
qui a tué des gens ah vous pensez donc
que tous les musulmans je vous pose une
question mais vous répondez pas à ma
question quel est votre question vous
détestez les musulmans
pourquoi les gens qui ont tué 283 de mes
compatriotes mais vous pouvez raconter
n'importe quoi et quand vous sur Twitter
on est d'accord
qui fait du mal même pas au delà de chez
juste qu'il fait du mal à quelqu'un moi
j'accepte pas ça
non il doit pas être suspension voilà
alors non non il doit pas être non non
non non
non je pense aussi que votre compte ne
doit pas être suspendu avant la liberté
d'expression
vous vous êtes vous dites quoi je suis
pour la censure totale par rapport à
Monsieur Rieu
pour fond une communauté qui propage la
haine donc je suis pour la fermeture et
là pour moi ça ne devrait pas se
discuter ça devrait mettre automatique
vous êtes un danger pour la société
française et j'espère que vous serez
très rapidement réduit médiatiquement au
silence vous aimez pas la liberté
d'expression j'aime pas vos idées
néfastes j'aime pas qu'on
attaquement ça va ensemble s'il y a pas
de liberté d'expression il y a pas de
démocratie monsieur Verdun vous ne
pouvez pas lire les musulmans comme vous
les haïssez et oui est-ce que vous avez
eu un traumatisme dans votre enfance
pour être soumis à l'islam que vous
monsieur se réveille voilà vous avez
même changé de prénom monsieur je suis
fier
je suis fier de la liberté
de génération
identitaires je suis fier de ne pas être
un extrait comme vous je suis fier de
mes idéaux et je vous déteste pour tout
ce que vous pensez monsieur je vous
déteste non pas humainement mais tout ce
que vous propagez c'est ce que je
voudrais qu'on interdit dans la société
française je ne suis pas d'accord avec
vous mais je défendrai votre droit à
dire ce que vous venez de dire alors
donc vous pensez qu'il faut assurer sur
les réseaux alors Marco Moulis qui sera
au séminaire mindset et action le 11
mars 2023 à Saintes entrepreneur et
homme d'affaires internationales
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est pourquoi c'est parce que
j'ai envie de faire gagner de l'oseille
aux gens et j'ai tellement facile avec
tous les problèmes qu'on a c'est
tellement facile de
propager et de travailler le problème
c'est qu'il m'a choqué lui je vais
arriver même plus à parler franchement
il m'a vraiment choqué le fond pour de
vrai tu m'as choqué grave grave alors
vous me tutoyer ouais je pourquoi tu
veux que je le vois lui il respecte le
qui lui maintenant le plus important je
veux te demander quelque chose dans les
pays musulmans oui pourquoi tu as été
pour faire l'humanité parce que dans ces
pays les chrétiens notamment les Juifs
sont en danger donc il faut les aider
alors
je suis vicieux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que toi tu es pour eux le compte
de l'Amérique ni monsieur ni
mademoiselle parce que malgré tout je
trouve que les tweets disent beaucoup
des gens ça dit beaucoup effectivement
peut-être d'une haine des musulmans de
la part de Monsieur et en même temps
pardon mademoiselle mais vous m'avez pas
convaincu sur fait partie de ces
personnes quand elles parlent qui qui
prennent des grands mots machins qui ont
jamais des phrases très nettes
je trouve que effectivement le côté
pardon à dire que je ramène tout à moi
mais c'est simple d'avoir une existence
la religion catholique ne reconnaît même
pas qui on est et la vôtre visiblement
nous brûle bon on aurait pas de bol mais
c'est vrai que si vous avez retweeté je
connais pas le tweet de quelqu'un qui a
ses idées où il faut tuer les
homosexuels et que vous me dites oui je
ne savais pas qu'il pensait ça alors je
vous dis juste la prochaine fois
renseigner sur renseignez-vous sur qui
vous retweetez quand on retweet faut
savoir qu'il est mais
dans la pub je te dis que j'ai pas
retweeté ce monsieur en fait vraiment
c'est
mais j'ai pas été ce monsieur
c'est quelqu'un qui a une image avec la
citation de ce monsieur et laquelle
citation et on lit la station je l'ai
pas lu quand vous me l'avez montré mais
allez la lire une citation d'une
personne qui est pour brûler les
homosexuels c'est comme ça
mais c'est comme si moi j'avais liké une
citation d'un
directeur ou quoi
j'ai complètement savoir qui qui était
ce qui était ce monsieur mais je ne
savais pas son son avis sur le sur le
sur les homosexuels c'est ça c'est il a
dit qu'il fallait tuer les homosexuels
homosexuels et d'ailleurs je demande aux
téléspectateurs de parcours monsieur de
vérifier quand même les informations
parce que moi j'ai jamais entendu ça
c'est pour ça que je vous dis non
seulement je savais pas mais je suis
même pas sûr qu'il l'ait dit et j'ai pas
envie de dire des bêtises ici
contrairement à ce monsieur je vais
vérifier mes informations et du coup moi
j'ai aimé parce que la citation m'a plu
rien de plus après si parce que j'ai un
voile et j'ai aimé on pense directement
que je suis au foie je trouve ça bien
triste et libre à toi c'est important
vraiment
penseur qui fait des belles citations
bah vous likez Voltaire ou quoi c'est
pas pareil que la quelqu'un qui
visiblement a des idées particulières
donc encore une fois soit vous avez été
sur ce sujet là un petit peu inculte et
je vous pardonne soit vous vous voilà
soit c'est horrible mais dans tous les
cas faites attention à ce que vous
souhaitez les parents j'ai aimé un
compte Twitter qui a en fait c'est très
simple
de quelqu'un oui mais je passe sur les
mots vous avez likez partagez
quelqu'un
Béatrice vous vous appelez moi je suis
contre la censure hors du cadre de la
loi donc je suis pas pour censurer ni
monsieur si quelqu'un a un problème avec
ce qu'il dit qu'il l'attaque en justice
et la justice tranchera maintenant je ne
suis pas non plus pour censurer madame
chacun doit s'exprimer chacun doit être
clair avec ce qu'il dit il me semble que
voilà les gens sont clairs le débat le
mérite d'exister sur votre plateau et je
vous en félicite parce que ça montre
qu'on est un pays civilisé on peut avoir
des des idées complètement différentes
et quand même venir ici de façon
civilisée et en parler même si on s'aime
pas même si on se déteste voilà et et
c'est pour ça aussi que j'aime cette
émission et que chacun ait ses opinions
et puisse dire ce qu'il a envie de dire
voilà quand le cadre de la langue oui
moi je suis pour la censure parce qu'il
y a une grande injustice sur les réseaux
en ce moment en fait on a d'un côté des
comptes qui sont détenus par des
anonymes qui sautent des gens qui
donnent juste leur avis et de l'autre
côté on a des soi-disant lanceur d'air
qui sont certifiés donc ils sont
soi-disant source de fiabilité qui
utilisent des fake news pour répondre
des idées dégueulasses moi je trouve que
vos propos ils sont infâme je trouve que
vous transpirez la haine vous respirez
le seum et que en plus vous êtes là je
vous ai même pas dire le fond de votre
pensée pourquoi au lieu de perdre votre
temps à faire des enquêtes à poster des
photos pourquoi vous ne twittez pas le
fond de votre pensée j'aime pas les
Arabes j'aime pas les musulmans c'est
plus simple au moins
[Musique]
je combats le fait que la France si cela
mise par le phénomène de l'immigration
puisque cette islamisation elle ne vient
pas elle ne pas dans les prairies
normandes donc par le phénomène de
l'immigration qui entraîne une
initialisation ça se fait très
rapidement et ça a des conséquences très
importantes sur nos vies sur notre
quotidien sur notre sécurité aussi sur
nos codes culturels on est obligé de
changer la manière dont on mange on est
obligé d'adapter nos lois on est obligé
de l'alimentaire ici moi par exemple
madame j'ai vécu dans le quartier de la
Guillotière par exemple il y a que des
commerces halal donc si je ne veux pas
manger à l'ail je fais comment
expliquez-moi et bah vous allez pas
chercher la Guillotière
encore une fois les filles c'est tout
entier aujourd'hui par exemple on ne
peut pas se promener en jupe monsieur
est d'accord avec ça
non c'est pas vrai
c'est magique et c'est vrai que quand tu
as raison il faut dire les choses très
clairement vous avez une haine viscérale
de l'islam une viscéral des Arabes et
tout ce que vous disiez ça ce n'est que
elle et je à la limite plus vous parler
et plus les gens comprennent les
Français ne sont pas idiots le débat que
vous faites il est je pense stupide il y
a effectivement les terroristes et c'est
de voilà de tout horizon et c'est
surtout voilà et franchement je trouve
que c'est amalgame là il est danger
parce que c'est le même discours que
tout le monde fait depuis des années et
ça ne sert à rien
je sais pas vraiment Dieu sait que je
connais mal la religion et tout je me
lance de rien mais de quel quartier vous
parlez dans lequel
avait niché par exemple on peut on peut
se balader sûrement en mini-jupe avec
bien sûr que oui
vous allez montrer la dernière fois
je fais juste dire quelque chose
qui est très gênant dans votre monsieur
c'est que vous mettez un signe égal dans
tout c'est-à-dire immigration égale
Islam égal islamisation égale terrorisme
vous mettez vous mettez tout le temps le
signe égal ce qui fait qu'il y a aucune
nuance dans votre propos et ce qui fait
qu'on ne peut même pas débattre parce
qu'en fait vous avez déjà un angle vous
avez déjà une grille de lecture cette
grille de lecture c'est que l'islam de
lecture c'est le réel mais non c'est pas
forcément le Real monsieur c'est votre
réel c'est que c'est votre grille à vous
bah écoutez pardonnez-moi mais
l'immigration il me semble il me semble
que 99,9% des musulmans souhaitent
simplement vivre tranquillement sous les
lois de la République en France pardon
mais que vous tous les musulmans veulent
être sont des terroristes je pense que
sur la proportion et notamment chez les
plus jeunes où on voit que plus ils sont
jeunes plus ils sont radicaux on est
autour de 25 30% qui par exemple
considère que la charia est supérieure
aux lois de de la République donc chez
les jeunes musulmans ils sont toujours
addicts les anciens islamisation une
radicalisation alors justement
génération justement
je vous remercie de d'y répondre ne
voyez pas du tout une provocation de ma
part
moi je voudrais savoir précisément pour
vous donc les lois de la République sont
largement au dessus des lois de la
religion moi je considère que oui par
exemple en France j'estime que
évidemment les lois de la République
sont au-dessus en France ou
personnellement ah non en France ok
d'accord en France et personnellement on
est voilà donc toutes les religions sont
en dessous des lois de la République de
mon pays et ben je voulais savoir vous à
titre personnel comment je vais lever
ambiguïté qui ne devrait pas en être une
pour moi et je vais répondre pas pour
bien me faire voir je vais vraiment
répondre avec enfin avec la toute
transparence qu'on connaît avec mon
coeur et pour moi il y a c'est un faux
dilemme et je vous le dis très
honnêtement bien sûr que lorsqu'il faut
respecter les lois de la République je
le fais et je le fais tous les jours de
ma vie et mon casier judiciaire est
vierge mais pour moi j'ai jamais été en
fait en contradiction il y a eu aucun
moment de ma vie j'ai voulu respecter
les lois de la religion et j'ai pas pu
le faire et à aucun moment si vous
voulez
le voile islamique dans les tribunaux
vous avez voulu que les tribunaux
puissent
actuellement aussi oui voilà et donc la
loi ne le permet pas donc vous êtes bien
avec la loi de la République là-dessus
renseignez-vous alors
du coup c'est des règlements intérieurs
réglement intérieur et je vais et je
verrai pas
de la répéter il y a une petite
ambiguïté c'est pour ça moi je veux dire
que c'est
franchement
parce que pour moi mais je suis très
honnêtement
encore
je peux vous poser moi aussi une
question mais comme ça parce que en vrai
de vrai cette question elle est sur tous
les plateaux télé comme ça on en parle
une bonne fois pour tout l'égalité
c'est une évidence par exemple c'est une
évidence absolue très beau aussi bien de
la République que dans les lois de ma
religion par contre c'est connu
d'ailleurs que dans les pays musulmans
l'égalité homme-femme c'est pas pareil
est-ce que vous pensez que je suis pour
le fait que les femmes en Iran soit
obligé de porter le voile vous pensez
que je suis pour ça non je pense surtout
mais oui ou non je pense mais oui
surtout madame que vous êtes ambiguë
vous êtes aujourd'hui face à des
Français qui sont hostiles à
l'islamisation de leur pays et donc vous
avez ici
ce qu'il est possible de dire
puisqu'on en a souvent parlé ici ça a
été un vrai sujet par exemple
ne soyons pas témoigner de mon humanité
franchement je trouve ça super plaisir
par exemple du PSG qui avait refusé de
porter par exemple un maillot pour la
lutte contre l'homophobie est-ce que
c'est par exemple quelque chose que vous
pourriez porter un maillot pour lutter
contre l'homophobie contre l'homophobie
contre l'antisémitisme et quand toutes
les haines voilà
c'est la République et de ma religion
c'est ça qu'il faut que les gens
comprennent dichotomie entre les deux ce
soir
[Musique]
[Rires]
moi la justement de la République c'est
la laïcité et la laïcité assure ma
liberté de conscience donc en fait pour
moi ça se rejoint tout ça c'est vraiment
et en fait j'aurais pu vous dire pour me
faire bien voir et pour vous dites c'est
une musulmane gentil j'aurais pu vous
dire ah oui Léo de la République bien au
sud de ma religion mais ça serait vous
mentir parce que pour moi j'ai jamais
été bah oui parce que j'ai jamais été
dans cette chanson en tout cas je dirais
jamais que je respectais les lois de ma
religion tout de suite de la République
en fait pour moi il n'y a pas de choix à
faire c'est un faux dilemme et
j'aimerais que vous me disiez une
situation où l'on se retrouve que je dis
les lois de la République sont
supérieures et le mari
voilà mais moi il y a pas de mais non
plus je vous dis juste seulement que
j'ai pas eu à faire ce choix là que j'ai
pas ce dilemme là j'espère avoir été
clair
en fait moi je préférerais que vous
repartiez des voilà des des gens qui ont
fait des des actes horribles et on dit
voilà cette personne qu'elle soit
musulmane ou catholique ou autre on
repartage parce qu'en fait tout ce qu'on
veut nous tous dans notre pays c'est que
ça se passe bien que les lois soient
durcis et que les gens qui foutent la
merde ne enfin soit vraiment puni mais
en fait c'est pas c'est pas au final une
question de religion parce que en fait
en pointant du doigt des gens qui ont
une religion et donc une spiritualité et
Dieu merci on en a tous même si on a des
dieux différents en fait c'est ça qui
est beau donc je trouve que c'est un peu
un faux combat parce que sinon vous
mettez ces gens-là qui prient vous les
considérez comme des perturbateurs alors
qu'au final s'il paye leurs impôts ils
sont correct avec leur voisins et s'ils
font ici voilà ils travaillent il y a
pas de souci voyez en fait je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui il est vraiment en 2023
vous êtes dans un faux débat alors que
vous voulez le bien pour la France et
vous les protéger votre pays mais
protégez votre pays c'est vous battre
contre les gens pas vraiment du mal et
les gens qui ont une spiritualité par
définition ne font pas de mal est-ce que
les Français ont le droit de s'inquiéter
de l'islamisation de leur pays ils ont
le droit d'être la mondialisation a fait
que tout le monde parle anglais
maintenant que tout le monde sait
mélanger
ifope
il y a des photos
c'est pas de la religion
ça pourrait être par un fou de n'importe
quel mais
ça dérangé
ici en tout cas ici en France il y a 263
morts de l'islamisme et je suis je suis
désolé ce qui s'est passé si les parents
sont acquis aujourd'hui c'est parce que
il y a du terrorisme islamique
en France mais
non c'est pas en France alors je voulais
quand même dire que Monsieur Rieu qui
est en face de nous c'est quelqu'un
heureusement qui a été très vite
condamné qui voulait récupérer le
meurtre horrible de la petite Lola vous
vous souvenez cette petite jeune fille
qui a été assassinée et donc vous avez
voulu récupérer politique récupérer ça
veut dire quoi récupérer ça veut dire
que j'ai envie que ça se reproduise pas
j'ai récupéré monsieur j'ai pas envie de
faire le live sur les réseaux sociaux
bonsoir Monsieur hier soir à la gare du
Nord il était sous occupé
hier soir
sur les autres ils twitch sur Nordahl
hollandais et tu passes sur les
pédophiles blancs oui c'est une fixation
c'est musulman et moi en fait
beaucoup de peine parce que vous êtes là
à sortir des chiffres moi je suis avec
vous pour les gens du Bataclan les
terroristes ont tué les gens du Bataclan
je suis avec vous ce qu'on a arrosé sur
les terrasses de restaurant je suis avec
vous il y a pas il y a pas discuter mais
c'est combien de musulmans en France il
y a combien
de musulmans vous savez combien
aujourd'hui parce que depuis tout à
l'heure ton frère
il veut pas me répondre combien de
musulmans
en France on estime entre 5 6 7 mois
de vivre en paix ils sont obligés de
supporter vos conneries tous les jours
parce que il y a trois connards qu'on
fait un attentat au Bataclan vous êtes
obligé tous les jours de mettre des
trucs sur les musulmans il y a pas des
musulmans selon vous répondez moi il y a
pas des musulmans qui sont en paix qui
vont travailler le matin qui payent leur
loyer qui paye attendez qui paye les
impôts qui sont en paix qu'elle aime les
enfants
vous voulez en faire quoi de cela ils
sont français l'identité française vous
voulez en faire du Pakistan ils
partiront jamais la question
supposée arrondissement qu'elle est
arrivé
arrondissement avec votre poche vous
divisez les gens qui se bagarrent dans
la rue c'est ça que vous êtes en train
de
je nie pas les problèmes je nie pas les
quartiers halal je dis pas qu'il y a des
quartiers où il y a que du halal je la
vois la réalité je viens avec toi quand
tu veux cet été je viens avec toi quand
tu veux cet été avec une robe avec une
fille en robe et on va voir si elle a
pas marché
pas dans l'immigration tu as pas
d'immigration dans son village il doit
il entend lui il dit ah bah oh là là
vite Le Pen oh là là tu as vu ce qu'il a
dit Damien dites-le Pen c'est pour ça
que vous êtes dangereux et c'est pour ça
que je vous déteste non moi j'ai pas la
science infuse chacun vote qui veut je
respecte les électeurs
du Front national je dis pas qu'il y a
pas de problème en France mais vous
mettez dans la tête des gens une haine
que vous vous ne vivez pas est-ce que
vous n'avez pas dans les quartiers vous
vivez pas avec les gens mais la banlieue
vote pour la je te dis pas le contraire
parce que il y a des problèmes je dis
pas qu'il y a pas de problème je dis que
ce mec là avec sa pochette et son
Twitter dans son salon il fout le bordel
pour y aller bah c'est clé des problèmes
d'écrire le réel ça ça vous dérange pas
du glace pourquoi tu parles pas bien
français
il est fatigué j'ai envie de parler
d'amour fatigue
pose ta question après je si vraiment
votre attention c'était de sauver la
France est-ce que vous pensez que vous
savez la France sur Twitter parce que
mise à part attiser sincèrement est-ce
que vous proposez des solutions à ce que
ce que vous dénoncez déjà vous savez je
ne fais pas que Twitter mon amour
je pense qu'il y a un danger une grande
partie des Français ont peur de
l'islamisation ne veulent pas qui la
France change de culture est-ce qu'ils
ont le droit est-ce que vous le
reconnaissez souvent des questions vous
proposer quoi est-ce que un peuple a le
droit de conserver son identité qu'il a
reçu de de ses ancêtres et de la
transmettre à ses enfants
lutter enfin vous préserver
des millions de catholiques et que
l'Arabie Saoudite devenait de plus en
plus catholique est-ce que les cerve
bien est-ce que les Saoudiens auraient
le droit de dire nous on a envie de
rester un pays musulman on préférerait
que c'est notre culture
parce que moi j'ai une dernière question
avant de recevoir la mienne c'est le
droit des peuples à rester eux-mêmes
parce que il y a la ministre qui nous
attend on va là-bas juste
il y a elle est sympathique elle est
souriante elle est intelligente elle a
un épiderme magnifique
ce que vous pourriez tomber amoureux de
c'est une question c'est pas c'est pas
conduire une question
tu sais tout va boire un diabolo
alors dites-lui je tais-toi non mais
la vérité la culture française la
civilisation européenne forcément je
préfère les femmes qui ont une qui porte
une culture française et une culture une
jeune fille elle a plein des comme ça en
tout cas elle ne porte pas la culture
française
je voulais juste dire mais pas pour vous
parce que je pense que je vous ai déjà
assez donné assez de temps mais c'est
pour tous les personnes qui regardent
Benjamin Castaldi vous l'avez très bien
dit tout à l'heure les Français ils sont
pas cons et je voudrais demander aux
Français non musulmans de bien ouvrir
les yeux ce qui montre ce monsieur sur
Twitter c'est pas la réalité quand vous
sortez dans la rue il y a absolument pas
ça vous avez tous des voisins des
collègues des amis musulmans et vous
avez très bien que la vraie vie c'est de
vivre ensemble la vraie vie c'est pas ce
monsieur et le visage de la France
ça marche bien
le vivre ensemble
l'idéal on a fait trop long là-dessus
non à 66% oui à 33%